You, Maester Hinkie, stand here accused of using the Dark Magic
known as analytics!
This here knucklehead
has blasphemed against the ways of the old school!
This heretic would have me rest my players
I say RUN THEM ALL!
I mean, this notion that losing leads to winning
I mean, come on!
This guy used his sorcery to force me to make bad trade
and give him all my draft picks!
Well, I don't know about that, Vlade
These analytics fools would have you believe the earth is ROUND!
Do you see a curve anywhere?
I mean, I'm just asking questions
And now, with the hot hand
Ser Evan Turner is gonna light Hinkie on fire
from a mid-range distance
Commence THE LONG TWO!
Not clutch
You know, the guillotine is probably more efficient
Man, shut up, witch
Alright, let's try again to light the heretic on fire
Not today, Luddites!
It's Barack Obama!
A tan horse? Really?
That's right
It is I, Barack Obama
44th President of the Realm!
Defender of rational thought
and the use of data to make informed decisions
Show us your birth certificate!
I'll be taking the numbers man with me!
Thanks, Obama
But where will we go?
To a place far away
where innovation and new ideas are welcome!
The MIT Sloan Sports Analytics Conference!